NEXT WEEK.
BRET.
>> Bret: TREY YINGST IN
JERUSALEM, THANK YOU.
AN ACT OF WAR.
AND FOR THOSE OF THE WORDS OF
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO
SPEAKING ABOUT WHAT HE CALLED
IRAN'S ATTACK ON A SAUDI OIL
FACILITY.
IF PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ORDERING
NEW SANCTIONS ON IRAN AS HIS TOP
DIPLOMAT, SECRETARY POMPEO
CONTINUES TO MEET THROUGHOUT THE
REGION.
CORRESPONDENT BENJAMIN HALL
REPORTS TO MAKE MIDDLE EAST
NEWSROOM.
>> THE PRESSURE ON IRAN IS
MOUNTING.
TODAY SAUDI ARABIA LAID OUT
EVIDENCE THEY SAY PROVED IRAN
WAS BEHIND THE ATTACKS,
DISPLAYING CRUISE MISSILES AND
DRONES.
SHORTLY AFTERWARDS, POMPEO FLEW
TO DISCUSS THE NEXT STEPS WITH
THE CROWN PRINCE WHILE U.S.
INVESTIGATORS COLLECTED EVIDENCE
ON THE GROUND AT THE ATTACK
SITE.
HE ACCUSED IRAN OF ACTS OF
TERRORISM AND WAR AND RISKING
THE GLOBAL ENERGY SUPPLY.
>> THERE WERE NO AMERICANS
KILLED IN THIS ATTACK BUT
ANYTIME YOU HAVE AN ACTIVE WAR
OF THIS NATURE, THERE'S ALWAYS A
RISK THAT THIS COULD HAPPEN.
>> IN THE U.S., PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS ALSO RAMPED UP SOME PRESSURE,
SAYING HE HAD INSTRUCTED THE
TREASURY TO SUBSTANTIALLY
INCREASE SANCTIONS ON IRAN IN
WARNING OF FURTHER ACTION.
>> THERE IS THE ULTIMATE OPTION
AND THERE WERE ACTIONS LOT LESS
THAN THAT.
>> SAUDI ARABIA'S DEFENSE
MINISTER SAID 18 EUROS AND SEVEN
CRUISE MISSILES WERE FIRED FROM
THE NORTH THOUGH THEY WERE STILL
WORKING TO DISCOVER THE EXACT
LAUNCH POINT AND HE CALLED ON
ALLIES TO BACK THEM AGAINST THE
THREAT.
>> IRAN CONTINUED AGGRESSION,
THE SPONSORSHIP OF TERRORIST
GROUPS AND INTERFERENCE IN
COMMERCE PRESENT A COMMON THREAT
TO US ALL.
>> THE IRANIANS CONTINUE TO DENY
INVOLVEMENT SAYING THE REBELS
WERE DEFENDING THEMSELVES AND
THAT THEY DON'T WANT WAR, BUT
ADDING THEY WOULD RETALIATE TO
ANY ATTACK.
>> TO SAUDI ARABIA, THE
EMIRATES, AMERICA, CERTAIN
EUROPEAN COUNTRIES AND THE
ZIONIST REGIME, WHICH STARTED
THE WAR IN THIS REGION.
>> SAUDI ARABIA SAYS 50% OF THE
OIL PRODUCTION CUT BY THE ATTACK
HAS NOW BEEN RESTORED, CALMING
THE MARKETS AND EASING FEARS
THAT EMERGENCY RESERVES NEED TO
BE USED.
BUT IF YOU THE THREAT HAS GONE.
THE FACT THAT -- STRIKE
SEEMINGLY AT EASE AT THE LARGEST
OIL FACILITY IN THE WORLD, THAT
IS NOW THE GREAT CONCERN AND
CERTAINLY SAUDI ARABIA AND THE